back
okay well I reset the router hopefully
we can uh finish this project before
everything goes
y I still can't figure out the dam the
uh the stream
delay oh wait maybe the this is it
now I swear that they don't want you to
find this option so that you don't know
that you can't
um hold
on content maybe this one okay maybe
here I can mess with it
right I hit show
more
uh so this off should be good stream
latency that's a search on your channel
like the search bars don't take you
where you think that they would
man I knew that I like I saw it at one
point but like there's like I don't know
if maybe you just can't edit it from
restream live
here well I will tell you that this is
also on Twitch and they have better
latency if you want that um YouTube's
kind of not not the best on
that they really need to fix that
stuff I don't need what am I doing I
don't need
so I saw a message delay I thought that
that was an increased message delay I'll
look at it one more time for you but I'm
pretty sure this was for increasing
message delay
whoops
content
live look so if you look
at where is it
customization message delay right
this just lets you send fewer messages
there's no option to make this
better so I don't think they have it it
does look like the stream is more stable
now I took the uh I took the chat
moderation off so at least hopefully
maybe it stops censoring links now and
maybe it stops like trying to do dumb
stuff yeah you're spamming messages and
it's not blocking you so I think that
it's good
now which is what we
want
uh okay so we still have to figure this
out um
I I'm kind of at a loss here is the
let's see if we can get back to the
earlier
web okay so now we have our game back
right this
hope okay we're not even getting errors
so I'm assuming that this is not
building
correctly cuz before we at least got
errors when we did this so maybe we have
wrong flag
yeah we need to at least get to a point
where we're getting
errors otherwise there's nothing we can
do
and there's nothing to debug there's
nothing to debug
right what happened before
we had
this well
files how is this not giving us anything
whatsoever to work with
like this works still right
yeah and then you click this and it
screws up the whole page and it lags a
bunch and nothing right
see why can't I even see any of the
files
can't I get the RB icon that's about
it uper mooba
it's got to just not be building
correctly at all right
I have the simpler example right I have
the snake and it
works okay so this is getting updated
the file is the files are being
updated um I mean is there something I'm
just screwing up in
command this is the one that we have
oops
this is the one that we have for snake
it's like the same Command right we have
embedded some extra files that's
for got any inso for final year project
University going back for third year in
October depends what you're depends what
you're experienced with and what you're
working on
right I mean if it's like General
software that can be literally anything
I can show you the type of stuff that
I'm doing at the moment um if I actually
can make it work here like it works not
on web
yet we're trying to figure out why it
won't build for web but if I just do
this I wouldn't suggest trying to do
something this large obvious and I
disabled the AI so they're not doing
anything down there but we have a little
MOBA kind of miniature version of
DOTA and uh yeah you can play this and
this is runs super super fast so this is
going to be good for reinforcement
learning this is my current project we
have some people around in the community
that are building like simpler
environments things like uh on the scale
of like a classic Atari
game we have a few of those going on in
the Discord you can check uh Discord
GPU if you want to do that if it's just
generally ml related not reinforcement
learning then you can kind of just throw
you know a model on any data
set if you're looking for stuff like
this we have where is this
trying to see if we have any of these I
remember people posted them I don't know
what channel they posted them in
though maybe
here oh
yeah somebody built like a a clone of
dopus building this we can do RL on
this he's going to be done with his
thesis in a week and he'll be working on
this stuff for a little
bit we also have simpler stuff like uh
where is
it all right here's pong but written in
like scyon so it runs stupidly stupidly
fast so we can train this thing at like
a million steps per
second and then somebody did a breakout
one as
well just like ultra high perf optimized
versions of the original Atari
games so yeah I mean this is kind of the
type of stuff that's going on around
here at the
moment the cool thing is with puffer lib
we can train really good models on these
really fast for
have to check the Discord
yeah that's the puffer
Discord I really don't see anything
wrong with this at the moment is the
problem
instead I would invest on
puff so that you know that the uh that
post in the Discord is funny because
like it's not like we can't get funding
it's simply that I don't think it's
worth it to try to get funding like it's
not like the money isn't free you
realize right it comes with a bunch of
strings
attached I've had like a good half dozen
VCS try to chat with me about that since
I graduated and I haven't even like and
that's with me saying that I'm not
taking
money and like not remotely trying to
make this like an appealing thing to
invest in I'm just doing cool
code so we can definitely go that route
if we want but I don't think that you're
going to be as happy as you think you
would be for
okay
so this om with 256 Megs of memory
somehow
oh yeah of course it does because we
allocate
yeah we'll we'll try 512
actually because I think what's going on
I might have an idea what's going on we
might just be like we have this gigantic
tensor oops hold on let me read that in
a second
second really interested in researching
hive mind neurom
Mets do you think that's a good topic
for someone new to
ml do I think that a completely uh a
nearly completely unexplored area of
research is a good place to start with
for somebody with no experience no I
would say it is not uh now if you want
to get a little closer to something that
has been explored you could do say
neurocellular automa those are really
cool and really fun to work
with do you know what neural cellular
automa
are that's like something you could
probably you could probably Jam
like here I'll show you something that
was made by uh
a a master
student very talented one mind
you this guy was at open AI I believe
around when I was
there so
all of these operations are implemented
as
convolutions so this is like cellular
autom e but then there's also like
no
errors no
issues so it does run
with it does run with 512
Megs but it doesn't do anything
like I can only debug what I have an
error for right
I can't debug the thing just being black
it's just
like I'm not even getting it's like not
loading the program or something
right like why don't I see any of the
files in here or anything
this
works
doesn't it takes forever to load
zoom is there like a an error flag or
something that I had
dev I thought there's a flag you can
pass to get errors
how are there still no
errors like what is in this HTML
why does none of it show up like I don't
even see I should see the HTML file at
least in here somewhere shouldn't
right and I go to sources
this is here
right is it stuck in an infinite Loop or
some [ __ ]
here I did not know that was a thing
what is it
this I mean it could be infinitely
looping on
yeah so this is not even
like there's nothing
we have to figure out why this doesn't
work because we're not doing
wsl2 yeah we'll fix the lag something's
weird don't this is ultra high perfect
it'll be fine
okay so let's actually try now we go
back to forcing webgl2 right
this I want our artist friend
uh I would like our artist friend to be
able to come back to seeing like you
know their artwork online that'd be
I've had professors to say wait hold on
what's your
stance on using chat GPT to learn and
debug
stuff the key is you can use chat GPT
you just don't use chat GPT to think for
you that's the key now I tell you I will
tell you what I I I will tell you what I
use I don't use chat GPT to build stuff
for me I use it essentially to look up
like obscure bugs and documentation
where it would be really hard to find
them online these days um I and like I
don't even use it that much like you'll
see me open it when I'm doing something
I'm really unfamiliar with like this web
development uh like this web ecosystem
stuff but for the most part this is what
I
suggest you can use co-pilot as well um
but I use this and I use it like do you
see how they're writing on Line Auto
completes so I use it to complete one
line at a time and it saves typing not
thinking it's like a 30% % productivity
boost probably just by typing faster uh
and getting like you know getting that
out of my way that's what I
suggest all the people that are like
using cursor to do like to try to do
everything for him or not learning
anything bad idea
extensions I haven't tried co-pilot
lately but when I used co-pilot
originally yeah super maven uh do you
use when you use co-pilot are the
suggestions
instantaneous that's the key thing you
need the suggestions to be instantaneous
oh last I used it no yeah so super Maven
it gives you very fast completions
that's the
it d platform web I bet you that we need
to pass this in order for it to use uh
webg
3 cuz I bet you D platform web tells it
to use the wrong
API that's what I think is happening
okay so apparently it needs to version
this and also let me just make sure that
it actually still
runs because I don't know if that
version if I'm using features from
later yeah so this doesn't
work blsl 3.0 is not
supported we'll copy this over just real
quick just to see
okay
so we have to figure out why it's so
slow should be able to be much faster
than this but we got like the shitty
version of the renderer working
let's try um hold
on
that doesn't do
anything it's still
slow but why is it
slow well this one doesn't work right
so let's fix that
it's weird like why it has this for
performance right
idea yeah I think I have an idea why
this is
there's I need to rewrite the way that
this function works here because
it's it's just locking performance up I
see yeah the FPS counter is accurate
it's just that it's not giving me
control back
least I think all I have to do is pass
inch
frame
here and then I go like this
works yeah okay so that now just runs
stupid Ultra fast
and
yeah now it's too fast right and too
responsive yeah look this thing is ultra
high per we just have like a screwy
thing with the rendering don't worry
about
it all
right I'm going to put this up here oh
and we can switch characters yeah we we
can switch characters
too so I'm going to leave this here for
a second I'm going to go use the
restroom and then we're going to
actually fix all this stuff up nicely
okay um yeah we'll do that
I yeah that's what we're going to do
I'll be right
Edition time to finish puffer web Ed
puffer mobile web
Edition man we're going to commit this
onto the site
today let's fix this though first
so let's do a little bit of Dev on the
desktop version in order to fix these
things cuz it's going to be easier than
to then port
I am enjoying C I am not enjoying mcrip
in JavaScript web let's go back to C for
a
second oh also let me prevent this house
from freezing me hold on
now wait do I
know
duh the frame rate is
correct but what it
and I think we need to do we'll have to
figure out the
shaders let's get this online first
Maybe
now
available in a browser near
you soon as I actually have this working
and commit it pretty
copy
right
build oh I'm dumb wait I'm dumb I'm very
dumb hold on we need to do it slightly
different so the thing is that like let
me explain this cuz this is like an
annoying uh browser thing so this here
in between iterations of this Loop is
the only time that the browser will give
you back control or you give the browser
back control so the way this actually
has to work we have in frame equal to
zero okay and then we do if frame perent
12 uh equals
and then you do
frame Plus+ you do render
game
right you only step every 12
semicolons I get hate for this but I
actually like Python's white space and
no
were
braces I very much like
it and
now prepare for buttery smooth in
browser MOBA
well it is smooth but it's it's
glitching hold
locally yeah know we get the exact same
thing
locally so that's correct um let me
think why this happens
and now we have to fix some Shader
issues like it's a little you can see
the screen vibrates a little bit it's
kind of weird
here let's try a different character
oops puffers you're in the
way what's this this is
support we also have to fix the AI
pathing so we can do that
okay fine it needs one gigabyte if I do
it this way
oh yeah okay that loads instantly right
and look there go the
puffers we follow the puffers into
battle Yeah
do the puffer hit
Tower back
off wait for
wave like a real MOA except their
glitches with the you know the shaders
but we'll fix those
got rid of some of
these
yep okay I mean so this is actually kind
of
playable I'm trying to figure out what
portions are actually
screwy I think it's just the uh like the
edges of the uh the screen that are
screwy right everything else is smooth
yeah it's just this Shader here that's
wrong so let's figure that
out it's so weird that we can't just use
two shaders though right like why can't
we do
that I'm trying to think if I want
to invest in debugging this obnoxious 10
Shader
okay yeah you do actually have to do
jail
one okay
we have to figure out what's wrong with
it and why it doesn't run
on desktop as well
program syntax
error unexpected new identifier
I think I have to put the string that
says uh
resource shaders okay so you have to
go they should be in a resource
wait do I not have this thing
starred I am very sorry Mr Ron there you
go there's your star
right
here
so they actually have the Shader here
like this Bloom Shader
all shaders must use same shading
language okay it just needs the string
language they are using the same oh wait
I I
language I think you have to set the
Shader thing wait uh this is in RB
examples
I don't want to write two versions so
can I just do
this uh glsl
is for
but I think it does want you to just
have two separate shaders
obnoxious I really don't like that at
all
well we may as well do it because it's
like that's the only way it's happening
today is if I just finished this I got
like an hour and a half to like get this
done I was making sure that there's no
feasible
alternative um but it looks like this is
what we have to
do and I hate this sort of preprocessing
stuff
here but
oops unless wait can we do
this no we already did this and it
didn't
Shader okay so now we have these
loading see if they work
path where's the Shader
path loaded
all shaders must use same shading
language
300 okay do I need to comment this thing
is this like
oh is it 3:30
here yeah so I got to go
330 wait I'm very confused hold on
3:30
okay 330 is loaded
there we go did the D platform thing do
anything I don't know if this actually
did
anything oh yeah that actually does
matter
huh you do actually have to pass it the
uh the platform for me
off
so we now have this working
right mean
[Music]
we'll fix the end of uh execution leaks
in a bit don't worry about
those and now we have to do the um the
web versions right
build we take forever building for some
reason probably because I'm embedding
the crazy pre-processing
stuff we'll do something to cat that no
worries
actually and now we should have web and
desktop versions with any luck
see yeah so if we look at this now right
we have our web version of the game
which has we a Shader that we have to
fix but we also have our uh our desktop
version of the game and they both run
smooth so let's figure out what's wrong
with this Shader
anything the compile cycle is just so
painfully
long why doing anything different is
such a
it doesn't look like it changed anything
does
still it looks like the checks are done
wrong or maybe it's just like
inconsistent I don't know we have to
figure this one out
let me see what I was actually passing
as the resolution before if I can figure
this
it this doesn't seem
let me see if I can just do this by
guessing essentially
what was it it was four before
right let's try 64 I
okay that's pretty close
right I think it was half of
this so let's do 32 and then we'll call
that good right
and then we'll be
good we'll be able to put this online as
like an initial test at the very least
to play around
with yeah this is exactly what it's
supposed to be it's still a little
iffy it's like a little
glowy it's pretty
good so we'll have a little bit of
Shader work to do left I'm sure
but I mean this is the
nice neutrals work as well right yeah
let me just make sure the neutrals
actually follow me they
should you follow me yeah you follow
me cool and you can try out all the
characters like there's the tank the
tank is really cool
because he has this like ridiculous AOE
Farm
ability he has a full
heal pretty cool you can even go on
check out the dire
team try out these guys too
right so uh yeah that's
nice let's see let's do a couple little
things with the
AI
press is going to be the
offset fly
okay then you're going to
BFS map you're going to take
AI paths up yeah s
address you don't have a buffer [ __ ]
okay so this what we're doing here is
instead of loading everything uh we will
pre-compute the paths as we need
them or we will compute the paths as we
need them and Cat them instead of pre
Computing which will be much faster
int this maybe
and
BFS I need to move this
stuff way the hell up don't
I I bet I can't put it this side because
it takes a map
oh okay so it does actually just want to
have this yeah okay
okay let's see if this does
it this new
now you can see that the puppers are
still paing
right is it
okay oh I think that this is a change I
see this changes
really should be able to free
this ah right here you're reading from
the file
fault I already freed
it for
hey how's it going pretty good we've
gotten uh most of this
stuff most of this stuff is set up I
think wait what void
I let's see if this is
correct no data and
texture all right we'll we'll have to
figure out how to free that texture in a
bit but I think this works so we've got
our local
demo this runs we can play we can die
before
this pretty
decent and then if
I compile this for
web and actually now if I compile this
for web
right I no longer need to include this
like stupidly gigantic
file so I should be able to go down
[Music]
to uh at most 5 12 megabytes
and this should build substantially
faster
yep and let's see if this runs on the
web if it if this runs I think we'll
just put it online we may as well just
put it online
this and and we're playing puffer mob in
browser and it doesn't take forever to
[Music]
load and there are few Q things that we
need to do but it's overall it's
decent overall
decent right yeah overall definitely
decent
right well done I'll put it online right
now so you guys can play
uh are there contributors I know I need
to add some contributors to
here to add bet and whoever I'll have to
ask them how they want to be added
are but that's
okay it's just the wome
file okay and uh we should do while I'm
here
get
add
Host we are now playing look at that
deployment we can now play puffer in
browser
W puffer beta now in puffer honestly
pre-alpha but in browser
we'll try to make it a little better
before we tweet it or
code uh let me check a couple things and
take a couple minute break just chill in
here and then what we're going to do is
we're going to fix up a couple things
that feel Jank okay that's awesome we
got 970 stars on the
project see if we have any more comments
on the
YouTube If you haven't seen this video
by the way I highly recommend this if
you're interested in RL
I'm honestly tempted to do this just
because I could probably make some money
and then fund research for the next 20
years oops yeah this this here this is
like come on hold on I hate this it
shows shows me ads on my own freaking
video come
on SO 25 26 minutes this goes through
like the whole reinforcement learning
stack like this is the most condensed RL
content you'll
find
Man play puffer MOBA vers RL in your
browser there's not really any RL you
can see because these guys aren't doing
anything yet but we'll get
my is it my Q my jump or my w my jump I
always
online oh there's so many people in here
that need to Star this
puffer star of the puffer people it's
free it helps me a
ton it's all I
ask I know what we're going to do we got
to fix there's a couple things that feel
janky with the uh the actions at the
moment so we'll fix those
probably push a new build
there I'm probably already start working
on neural Nets after
that of course it's 6:44 so we'll
probably I'm probably going to order my
food at 7
today a little
jillen playing some
MTG you know we were considering making
a puffer the Puffer ring environment
Magic the Gathering puffer the puffing
we could do a card game
environment we could totally do a card
game
environment I would definitely need
somebody who would want to assist on
that
though nobody's ever done RL Magic the
Gathering have they
what would that even look like I mean it
would look like you implement a stupidly
high performance card game like magic
the Gathering and then you try to get an
RL agent to learn to play it right
and then you make it different enough
that you don't get
so would you make your you'd make your
own
you'd have to make your own because you
want it to be ultra fast right I mean
yeah technically if like you're Wizards
and you just really wanted something to
work on the real like the full game like
that like I'd either have to make a way
higher per version of their client or of
their simulator or I'd have to implement
another that's like very close to
it I don't know it probably wouldn't be
that hard for
these need Sentinels on them I think is
what needs to happen
these oh this is this is
fine I literally just have to do
okay and then we just need to move this
stuff
up
puffer uh except that I'm dumb and I
forgot we still need to do this huh
this should feel way more
responsive if it
works so what should happen now is
that yeah the game should respond
instantly and I shouldn't have to worry
about like clicking
yeah you see like all my skills go off
immediately that's way
better that's actually a big enough
Improvement I'm going to make it push to
the web as
and that will be puffer the Puffer
ring um
now it works
instantly oh yeah that feels way
all
right well that is now
online you guys can play that if you
want and let me know how it
is oh yeah you got little
MOA should be a full screen buttton that
would be nice to like full screen it in
browser or whatever you can just do this
right it's basically the same thing
combo that's a pretty substantial Wason
build you don't often see like
substantial stuff get onto the
web like
this and the performance is like butter
you could easily Implement like a full
client on this could you imagine having
like your
full client for an actual game like your
full League of Legends or your full DOTA
client just be like yeah let's just go
to browser and run the thing and it's
just perfectly
fast
uh I think for actual competitive games
you'd want it on a desktop client
though let me order some food on the
side and then we'll figure out a couple
last things to
do uh on this for the time
being so I have not eaten and I am
hungry
okay that ought to be
good I remember playing Minecraft in
browser was that a
thing says
Java why play Minecraft in
browser when you can play puff or MOBA
in browser
MOA needs animations and stuff obviously
right
[ __ ] I don't know why it shifts like
this it's
yeah this tank character is crazy
broken just walks into
though next thing is going to be to get
the RL agents
um that's going to be a bigger task for
sure get the RL agents in yeah like
literally I can just sit here and do
this and they just die
can I even just take this tier whatever
this is on my
own yeah I literally can just take the
tower on my own it's
won
uh oh that's
funny it looks like there's a
bug yeah that's is definitely a bug I
think that the other Tower is still
hitting
me well we'll have to fix that lots of
things like this that are just going to
be from playing the game
more why don't we see if we can load up
the uh the RL agents into the other
version of the game let me see if that
works
because we do have this other version
here
right and I
think we should have uh some cool
policies
trained we also have the sweep to look
at right
holy just running longer and longer
experiments oh my look at this a 532
score on
breakout it's
crazy it's running long experiments
though for sure
this should be good
right radiant is just winning for some
reason
here let's see what this
uh this needs the original Shader I
believe hold on
now there we
go okay here's our team Let's go Team
reinforcement learned agent
team let's go let's get some picks come
on
okay we took a
tower and take another
Tower oh look the tank is just
destroying everything because it's a
broken
character and I lost I died here I got
to level four that's pretty good the
tank is still running it down mid
I don't know why dire side is not doing
anything also why I'm so
slow cool though they do run down mid
they get stuck they're not
great yeah they get stuck so these guys
are not super smart they do run down mid
but they're not very smart otherwi
wise
cool well we have a little bit of work
to do
um I'm trying to think how much I want
to Port the full policies to run on the
C
version like that would take a little
bit of work I'd need to Port the com
layer and the lstm layer to run in pure
C the main
I mean I'm going to want to do it
anyways at some point
like I don't know how you're supposed to
read any of this
function oh
here underscore
I'm getting food soon as
well
so it's uh CNN it's just calling the CNN
back end
right with all this
I have to figure out how to match the
freaking order don't
probably not that bad if I just make
like a C++ okay if I maybe this is what
I'll do I'm doing some stuff tomorrow
but maybe Friday what I'll do is I'll
like I'll make some
tests and I'll try to get uh matching
like I'll get a C++ file going it has to
be C++ for this one but uh I'll have the
C++ P torch implementation versus uh
like my own just C implementation and
we'll get those layers working correctly
so we can have a little neural net
library to run the policies in pure
C maybe that's what we'll
waiting for
order might call it early tonight let me
see if there's anything else going
here maybe we'll just start on it I mean
that'll be a cool thing to start on at
the very least right and we can use our
existing linear layer as a
test
this just want this
code screaming kids outside driv me
I thought I had a version where I did
torch snake or
one like I have this working somewhere I
got to find it
though I'll just write it
well I'll have to figure out the P torch
C++
well no because we need to replicate
their layers specifically right
to yeah we should be able to just like
copy this
oops and then what we can do is we
should be able to copy our
Network I'm tempted to just have GPT
convert this
so I don't really have much interest in
the stupid C++ API
yeah wait why am I doing this we have
the code for this right here
one for com
2D
three CNN channels
32 5 and then stride equals
two this
Channel channels
three
out uh it's occurring to me that the
lstm is going to be pretty difficult to
F to figure out and also I'm starving
and my food is almost here so I think
that this is going to be something that
I will think about and basically at some
point relatively soon I want to have uh
a pure c network or pure C library that
will allow us
to match the pie torch implementation
doesn't have to be crazy fast but uh
that will let us run inference on web
and uh in pure C loading just weight
files so I'm going to go get some
food
um thank you for tuning in if you
haven't already you can go ahead and
play these here uh but also start the
puffer if you haven't started the puffer
come on helps me out a
ton I'll put this in chat and uh if
you're looking to learn a bunch of RL
stuff in a very short amount of time I
have this new RL iceberg
video on
YouTube which I would highly recommend
watching other than that I got some
co-working stuff to do tomorrow so I
will probably be back on Friday thank
you and